keeping the good vibes going CNN anchor
and 60-minutes contributor Anderson
Cooper is beaming here's why so that's
why at Morgan Cooper my son he was he
was 7.2 pounds at birth and he is sweet
and soft and healthy and I am beyond
happy world meet Wyatt
Morgan Cooper who came into the world on
Monday Anderson named his son after his
father Wyatt who died when Anderson was
10 years old Morgan honors his late
mother's family Anderson says he's
grateful to his surrogate and all the
doctors who made this miracle happen
Gale you know Anderson is the reason I
have a career in journalism hiring me
straight out of my internship and
mentoring me to this day I'm not the
only one who Revere's him and this news
filled my heart with joy
oh gosh me too Vlad I was watching last
night live when he said it number one it
was such a surprise who knew certainly a
lot of people did but if the public
certainly didn't know but Anderson was
so Gideon so happy and just seeing that
made me happy and oddly enough Anthony
one of the first people I thought it was
Andy Cohen Anderson and Andy are best
friends Andy just had a baby recently so
I just see Ben and Wyatt being bonded
for life
I'm so excited and isn't it joy in this
particular time I'm over the moon about
this story yeah everybody should watch
Anderson's tribute to Wyatt there at the
end of that show it's just it's so
lovely and you
I hope Wyatt gets to see it one day
because he will know how much his father
loves it it's really lovely yeah